yo what is up everybody it is prestige
Amanda here with the second part to the
final boss fight in the clap tastic
voyage DLC as you saw there I just beat
eclipse and he drops a few weapons but
obviously that's like hardly any loot so
what else is there
there's Els so the Eclipse fight is
actually the only the first half of the
final boss fight and once you fight a H
source up shadow trap this is the second
form of shadow trap it has a similar
health scheme in terms of a lot of
shields actually know his shields aren't
too bad uses shields are less so than
eclipses and his health isn't his health
is larger however that is circumvented
by the fact that es can regen in a
different way than Eclipse couldn't so a
little bit about the fight heõs will
shoot Hills his biggest weapon is a
giant purple laser shot that'll he'll
attack you with I'm trying to think what
it's similar to um just think of the
Warriors uh Schlag tail like giant beam
um slag that is kind of what it's like
that is I'd say the most powerful shot
it also shoots a bunch of you can see it
there it also used a bunch of those
small blue lasers you see it has turrets
they grow out of it that shoot normal
like on just a normal armored turret
like laser shots normal Hyperion laser
shots and it has the moon shot Canon
because obviously as you can see it is a
smaller version of the Helios station
which is later I basically just run
around the map the entire time it's live
I do use my other tactic that I showed
you in the previous video if you didn't
see it go check it out of jumping up in
here you can come here if you ever about
to die however I find a lot easier to go
run around and shoot him because I feel
like I can't get a lot of hits on him a
lot of good hits on him from just this
one position cuz he circles around the
map and as you can see right now he is
nowhere to be seen
occasionally he will teleport into like
another dimension or something or a
different play
and he'll send a bunch of smaller
minions to attack you so just a bunch of
robots and stuff and they aren't too
hard to kill but you gotta kill a bunch
of them and then he'll appear while he's
in this other place he'll be Regenesis
luckily his shields aren't too aren't
they aren't too big so you don't have to
worry a lot about the shields getting
you there are gonna be a lot of minions
to get yourself up if you get down Don
so like the previous fight it's not too
big of a deal if you get down just be
careful now here's the end of the fight
I sped it up a little bit just to show
you some of the loot I get after the
fight and since I've been over basically
everything about the fight I do enjoy
the fight the entire fight between him
and Eclipse took me probably around an
hour and 15 minutes an hour and 20
minutes like an hour to an hour and 20
minutes somewhere in there but I I
definitely did the Eclipse fight really
slowly I did the Yeo's fight a lot
faster and as you can see there I killed
them it's not too hard to fight but it
presents a challenge and I think it I
think it is a pretty good fight there's
a lot of diversity in the kids that they
use there could be more there could be a
lot of more differences in how they
fight you but I I enjoyed myself do um
throughout the fight so I can't say that
I didn't like it and I can't not
recommend it if I enjoyed it you guys
might not enjoy it but that is a
preference thing so on as you can see
once you take the h source out of shadow
traps dead body he'll throughout a bunch
of Lu including some that special Pink's
that are exclusive to this DLC and I
actually was able to get a legendary I
got some form
I got a crotch frost Innova known it's
not nova a frost um
Major Tom I think it was called scout
Major Tom so yeah that's kind of all I
have for the video hope you guys have
enjoyed this I'll be putting up more
content about these DLC in the coming
days probably something about the just
over other just overview of the DLC
maybe something about how the new gun
system is working all that so I hope you
guys have enjoyed this video if you did
make sure you
all my other border lines up pre-sequel
videos and other stuff for my channel so
that's about it I'm gonna wrap it up and
hope you guys have a pretty swaggy
swaggy did he's that guys